design tutti apprezziamo il grande
design sono design estremamente iconici
come la valentine ci sono le sedie che
più o meno ogni designer pensa di
progettare in un momento della loro vita
apparentemente poi c'è design che
avviene dalla stampa quindi design
ibrido già in misto e quindi ci sono ad
esempio recente quando fusione di
software e hardware ma la domanda qui è
ok questi sono esempi di grande design
ma perché perché ci manca
l'abilità di fare un buon design non
eccellenza per forza ma continuamente
beh vorrei partire presupposto che il
design di base trans disciplinare è un
design che coinvolge e include
discipline multiple quindi sicuramente
la parte visuale ma anche la psicologia
a comprendere come verrà utilizzato ma
anche la tecnologia anche il business
perché bisogna capire come questo viene
poi portato agli utenti ma questo ci
porta poi a uno del problema che vuole
parlare oggi che ok ci sono grandi skill
che si possono avere
ma poi ci si scontra con lego lego si
scontra quel designer per un motivo
abbastanza semplice cioè ci immergiamo
nel lavoro che facciamo proiettiamo
tanto di noi stessi nel lavoro e quindi
quello che va a succedere e che ci
identifichiamo con il progetto con
l'idea con il concept con quello che è
stato realizzato e questo porta
ovviamente una commistione dell'io della
persona con il lavoro che viene fatto e
se ne prendiamo il termine i go go e
ovviamente ci sono tante definizioni
psicologiche molto specifiche ma ci sono
anche definizioni più comuni che è
quella che di solito viene utilizzata e
di solito viene utilizzata con
un'accezione negativa quindi il senso di
importanza di noi stessi la nostra
autostima che punto è positivo avere ma
nella connotazione negativa a causa
molti problemi e proprio perché leggo e
questa cosa che ci chiude dentro noi
stessi
leggo è anche il più grande nemico il
design che invece per sua natura
transdisciplinare interconnette le
persone e della necessità del buon
design e quindi l'impatto sulla persona
è grave perché neghiamo quello che sta
succedendo una persona con grosso ego
non è in grado di accettare le critiche
si chiude si difende talvolta anche
sfocia in rabbia c'è una disconnessione
emotiva che quindi non aiuta a capire
gli altri e ovviamente andiamo perdere
la capacità di crescita della persona
che non accetta più consigli che non
accetta suggerimenti
poi abbiamo però anche un impatto sul
design stesso perché questa incapacità
diminuisce la creatività del risultato
le creatività della soluzione la qualità
diminuisce non c'è possibilità di
sperimentare e ovviamente la mancanza di
diversità porta a una carenza del design
finale ed infine c'è un altro aspetto
che a quello del team è questo e molto
molto interessante perché è spesso
sottovalutato ma l'impatto sul team è
enorme ed è evidente nel lungo termine
soprattutto perché continui a degradare
le persone non si sente
responsabilizzate se quella persona
prende tutte le decisioni cosa ci sono
qui a fare la collaborazione viene
distrutta non viene dato potere alle
persone di gay e talenti individuali e
ovviamente abbassa il morale del team e
questo danneggia al gruppo la società
nel lungo termine e quindi dobbiamo
affrontare leggo
e per affrontarlo ci sono ci sono vari
modi ma partirei da una delle
spiegazioni bruno mari grande designer
italiano che in una delle sue lezioni
disse ok siamo siamo persone quindi
ognuno di noi avrà un suo stile al suo
quello che gli piace fare un suo talento
specifico ma quando mi proietto nel
design quando faccio design quello che è
messo da parte e crea qualcosa di
diverso per il prodotto per quello che
sto facendo a livello personale per
risolvere questo problema
la prima cosa da fare è separare
separare l'idea del libro questo questa
nostra difesa da quello che noi siamo
capire che non siamo noi e se vogliamo
dobbiamo iniziare a dire questa voce in
terra che dice io se iniziamo ad
accorgersi che esiste e iniziavano
accorgersi che non siamo noi
quello è il primo passo e vale per noi
soprattutto e questo viene da ricerche
nell'ambito della mindfulness della
meditazione delle neuroscienze è uno dei
modelli che è stato creato ci dice che
noi cerchiamo il focus
cerchiamo quel momento quella
concentrazione quell'abilità di trovare
il centro nel lavoro che facciamo nel
design che facciamo ma è impossibile
tenerlo a lungo e quindi il focus pian
piano degrada e va a inserirsi in questo
lupo in questo circolo vizioso di
pensieri e si connettono uno dopo
l'altro e continuano nella nostra testa
a connettersi uno di fianco all'altro e
leggo è questo circolo è uno di questi
circoli viziosi e la cosa interessante è
che un sacco del degli approcci si
focalizzano su come mantengo il focus
come riesco a mantenere a creare
condizioni ideali per il focus
ma dalle ricerche che sono fatto appunto
soprattutto nell'ambito della
mindfulness andiamo a scoprire che
quella è sicuramente uno degli aspetti
ma è altrettanto importante allenare
l'abilità di accorgersi quando siamo in
quel circolo vizioso e quindi saltare
fuori
e questa abilità può essere allenata
ovviamente le prime volte che lo
facciamo riusciremo a mantenere il focus
per l'un per cento del tempo e pian
piano questo si amplierà è un talento e
un'abilità che possiamo sviluppare e
questo riesce a rompere per noi al di
fuori del circolo vizioso che è che
leggo che questo sistema difensivo
oppure la cosa più semplice che possiamo
fare se ci accorgiamo che sta per
succedere
andiamo a fare una camminata e le
ricerche ci hanno detto che il miglior
modo di farlo è fare una camminata nel
verde a livello del design modi per
affrontare leggo ce ne sono vari e in
modo assolutamente interessante molti li
processi di design
se pur senza dirlo cercano di
minimizzare il ruolo del lego
nell'interno processo all'interno della
produzione del design uno dei trucchi ad
esempio pixar ed cat non ci racconta che
tutti e tutte le persone coinvolte nella
realizzazione di un film si trovano ogni
mattina condividendo qualunque tipo di
lavoro sia stato fatto il giorno
precedente può essere incompleto può
essere parziale non importa tutti
discutono di tutto e questo permette a
far diventare il lavoro dal lavoro
dell'individuo al lavoro dei tanti
permette di allenarsi ad affrontare
nostro ego e capire che giorno dopo
giorno dopo giorno lavoro dopolavoro
dopolavoro questo può essere affrontata
un altro aspetto estremamente importante
quello di criticare il design ma non la
persona
e molto facile dire a quel lavoro che
faccio è estremamente brutto dobbiamo
sistemare questo problema che che hai
nel tuo design
quando invece è molto più semplice dire
risolviamo assieme il problema del
design assieme il problema di questa
proposta che che abbiamo davanti
quindi la separazione aiuta perché ci
permette di dire permette di dire al
team che hai fatto un buon lavoro e
assieme andiamo a risolvere i problemi
rimanenti assieme andiamo a migliorare
quello che è stato fatto e quindi un
modo per evitare leggo
a livello del team è molto difficile
però capire quando c'è leggo considerato
come abilità di essere confidenti sicuri
di se stessi e invece l'arroganza la
differenza è che quando vado a
presentare
quando uno va a presentare davanti a un
team un gruppo dei vice president per
esempio una cosa entrare nella stanza e
dire presentare il design con sicurezza
con la ricerca che è stata fatta con le
idee che sono uscite e accettare
consigli e vedere come si può migliorare
assieme e un altro invece entrare nella
stessa stanza ma invece essere sicuri
che quello è il design migliore che
possa essere mai fatto talvolta queste
due da fuori è facile confonderle
soprattutto in un primo momento e per
distinguerle basta vedere come e quanto
la persona è in grado di ascoltare la
capacità di ascoltare e assolutamente
fondamentale perché non soltanto perché
il design come spesso in detto è un user
centric e centrato sull'utente ma anche
perché è importante portare assieme
tutti i consigli che possono arrivare
ovunque e questo ci permette sia a
lavorare noi sulla capaci di ascoltare
ma anche per riconoscere quale dei due
tipologie di ego ci troviamo davanti e
poi una cosa fondamentale la capacità di
dare merito la capitale dire queste
persone hanno aiutato nel progetto mi è
capitato veramente troppo spesso che
addirittura a livello di contratto
l'azienda vietasse di parlare del fatto
che io avessi lavorato ad un progetto
questo è assolutamente distruttivo e ora
potrebbe dire ma perché dare credito
dare credito non stimola leggo si è
fatto male si ma se noi pensiamo una
cosa leggo e anche lì perché ci vogliamo
essere riconosciuti e se ci troviamo in
un team in un gruppo di persone un
gruppo di lavoro dove sappiamo che se
abbiamo fatto un buon lavoro ci verrà
riconosciuto leggono una ragione di
attivarsi e dare credito può essere
fatto sia nel piccolo con un
ringraziamento
ovviamente è compensato al tipo di
lavoro che è stato fatto
ma se ci spostiamo dai consigli che
possiamo applicare ogni giorno sul
nostro modo il lavoro nel nostro piccolo
c'è una domanda che continua a tornare
nella mia testa perché continuiamo a
premiarlo perche continuiamo a celebrare
individui celebrare manager celebrare
grandi designer che invece dimostrano
tutti i tratti del lego negativo ci sono
effettivamente cioè baia 63 deviazioni
cioè noi percepiamo il bayern quando noi
percepiamo il mondo in un certo modo e
lo vediamo così in modo naturale è
naturale pensare un certo modo anche se
non ha né un interpretazione del mondo
negativa e ad esempio uno dei buyers è
quello della sopravvivenza cioè il fatto
che noi analizziamo solo le persone che
hanno avuto successo e non le migliaia
che non l'hanno avuto
analizziamo il design che ha avuto
successo e chi l'ha fatto e non tutti
quelli che hanno fallito e quando
andiamo a osservare più da vicino questo
ci accorgiamo che è molto spesso un
design una soluzione un'azienda non ha
avuto successo grazie a questo ego ha
avuto successo nonostante leggo un altro
byas molto grosso è quello che definisco
con un termine inglese smart che per
essa tradurre molto bene terra però
significa che sono state fatte delle
cerchie negli anni 80 e quando veniamo
proposti due feedback due consigli
assolutamente identici e uno o negativo
e un uomo posto in modo gentile quello
negativo veniva percepito come più
intelligente ma se noi percepiamo il
mondo in questo modo dobbiamo accorgersi
che forse dobbiamo fare una correzione è
assolutamente preferibile lavorare con
la persona più gentile è in grado di
proporsi in modo non confrontati va
quindi come possiamo superare questo beh
di baia si affrontano accorgendo insieme
e l'ultimo buyers è quello che chiamo
del genio solitario questa idea
celebrata incredibilmente dai media
si dice che è una persona che ha creato
è una persona che ha realizzato questo
grande design una persona che ha portato
avanti questa società questi tre by us
si uniscono assieme e ci portano a
celebrare queste persone che in realtà
hanno lavorato assieme in gruppi e ad
esempio se noi pensiamo a steve jobs che
viene celebrato per le società di design
per le sue abilità organizzative per il
suo genio per la sua abilità business ma
forse la sua abilità primaria è stata
quella a lungo tutta la sua storia di
essersi sempre affiancato con i migliori
talenti che trovava e non c'è bisogno di
andare tanto distante anche in italia
adriano olivetti grandissimo
imprenditore ha fatto grandissime cose
in italia una visione eccezionale ma
anche vi andiamo a vedere si circondava
di grandissimi design per esempio guy ha
creato dei concept store i negozi di
alimenti che si dice che sono state di
ispirazioni di quelli di apple e alcuni
se ne accorgono se ne prendiamo lady
gaga il suo team creativo a un brand le
persone che lavorano con lei sono
celebrate con un brand con una
identificazione particolare che ha
causato gaga e quindi lei capisce che è
difficile al mondo accorgersi tutte
queste persone che lavorano vs sono
assolutamente fondamentali per il suo
successo e ha creato un brand per
aiutarle a venire riconosciute in
definitiva il messaggio e affrontiamo
leggo affrontiamoli noi aiutiamo gli
altri affrontarne affrontiamolo nel
mondo del lavoro perché il design in
fondo è molto umile
il design di successo è umile per
definizione grazie